so understanding the human brain
is undoubtedly coupled
to how do we make better ai because so
much of ai
has in fact been inspired by the brain
it may have taken 50 years since the
early days of neural networks
till we have you know all of these
amazing progress
that we've seen with uh
you know deep belief networks and uh
you know all of these advances in go
and chess in image synthesis and deep
vagues in you name it
and but but the underlying architecture
is very much inspired by the human brain
which actually posits a very very
interesting question
why are neural networks performing so
well
and they perform amazingly well is it
because they can simulate any possible
function
and the answer is no no they simulate a
very small number of functions
is it because they can simulate every
possible function in the universe
and that's where it gets interesting the
answer is actually yeah a little closer
to that
and here's where it gets really fun uh
if you look at human brain and human
cognition
it didn't evolve in a vacuum it evolved
in a world
with physical constraints
like the world that inhabits us it is
the world that we inhabit
and if you look at our senses
what do they perceive they perceive
different you know
parts of the electromagnetic spectrum
you know
the hearing is just different movements
in air
the the touch etc i mean all of these
things we've built intuitions
for the physical world that we inhabit
and our brains and the brains of all
animals evolved for that world
and the ai systems that we have built
happen to work well with images of the
type that we encounter in the physical
world that we inhabit
whereas if you just take noise and you
add
random signal that doesn't match
anything in our world neural networks
will not do as well
and that actually um basically
has this whole loop around this which is
this was designed
by studying our own brain which was
evolved for our own world
and they happen to do well in our own
world and they happen to make the same
types of mistakes that humans make
many times and of course you can
engineer images by adding just the right
amount of
you know sort of pixel deviations to
make a zebra look like a bamboo
and stuff like that or like a table
but ultimately the undoctored images at
least
are very often you know mistaken i don't
know between muffins and dogs for
example
in the same way that humans make those
mistakes so
it's it's on you know there's no doubt
in my view that the more we understand
about the tricks that our human brain
has evolved
to understand the physical world around
us the more we will be able to bring
new computational primitives in our ai
systems
to again better understand not just the
world around us
but maybe even the world inside us and
maybe even the computational problems
that arise from new types of data that
we haven't been exposed
to but are yet inhabiting the same
universe that we live in
with a very tiny little subset of
functions from all possible mathematical
functions
yeah and that small subset of functions
all that matters to us humans really
that's what makes
it's all that has mattered so far and
even within our scientific realm
it's all that seems to continue to
matter but
i mean i always like to think about our
senses and how much of the physical
world around us
we perceive and if you look at the
um ligo experiment over the last
you know year and a half has been all
over the news what what did lago do
it created a new sense for human beings
a sense that has never been sensed in
the history of our planet
gravitational waves have been traversing
the earth
since its creation a few billion years
ago
life has evolved senses to sense things
that were never before sensed light
was not perceived by early life no one
cared
and eventually photoreceptors evolved
and you know the ability to sense colors
by sort of catching different
parts of that electromagnetic spectrum
and hearing evolved and touch evolved
etc
but no organism evolved a way to sense
neutrinos
floating through earth or gravitational
waves flowing through earth etc
and i find it so beautiful in the
history of not just humanity but
life on the planet that we are now able
to capture
additional signals from the physical
world than we ever knew before
and axions for example have been all
over the news in the last few weeks
the concept that we can
capture and perceive more of that
physical world
is as exciting as the
fact that we are we were blind to it is
traumatizing
before right because that also tells us
how you know we're in 2020. picture
yourself in 30 20
or in 20 you know what new senses why
might we discover
is it you know could it be that we're
missing
so physics that like there's a lot of
physics
out there that we're just blind to
completely oblivious to it yeah and yet
they're permeating us all the time yeah
so it might be right in front of us
so so when you're thinking about
premonitions
yeah yeah a lot of that is ascertainment
bias like yeah every you know every now
and then you're like oh i remember my
friend
and then my friend doesn't appear and
i'll forget that i remember my friend
but every now and then my friend will
actually appear i'm like oh my god i
thought about you a minute ago you just
called me that's amazing
so you know some of that is this but
some of that might be that
there are within our brain
sensors for waves that we emit
that we're not even aware of and this
whole
concept of when i hug my children
there's such an emotional
transfer there that we don't comprehend
i mean sure yeah of course we're all
like hardwired for all kinds of
touchy-feely things between parents and
kids it's beautiful between partners
it's beautiful etc
but then there are intangible aspects
of human communication that i don't
think it's
unfathomable that our brain has actually
evolved ways and sensors for it
that we just don't capture we don't
understand the function of the vast
majority of our neurons
and maybe our brain is already sensing
it but even worse
maybe our brain is not sensing it at all
and we're
oblivious to this until we build a
machine that suddenly is able to sort of
capture
so much more of what's happening in the
natural world so what you're saying
is we're going physics is going to
discover a sensor for love
for and maybe maybe dogs are off scale
for that
and we've been oh you know we've been
oblivious to it the whole time because
we didn't have the right answer yeah
and now you're going to have a little
wrist that says oh my god i feel all
this love in the house
i see i sense a disturbance in the force
[Laughter]
and dogs and cats will have zero none
none
you